[Music]
olaf carlson we is a 32 year old venture
capitalist and hedge fund manager
based out in california that runs a firm
called polychain capital
he's notable for a few reasons and one
he was the very first hire at coinbase
uh the largest cryptocurrency exchange
in the us and then he broke off in 2016
to to form uh one of the first crypto
venture in hedge fund
he became the the poster child when he
appeared on the cover of forbes in july
of 2017 at the height of the ico boom
the initial point offering boom that saw
the price of bitcoin first approached 20
thousand dollars before falling in
spectacular fashion but now he's um he's
riding high again uh his firm has more
than five billion dollars in assets
under management uh he just closed a new
venture round for 750 million dollars
although he tells us that he could have
raised many many many hundreds of
millions more than that and um he's
looking to deleverage polychain to build
a decentralized world that affects
everything from finance to online gaming
i've always been a fanatic about
cryptocurrency when i first got
exposed to bitcoin in 2011
after i was at coinbase for several
years i was spending more and more time
on what i would call kind of cutting
edge crypto technology at that time
ethereum was very nascent and it was
most of where i was spending my time
most of what i was thinking about
and i realized that there was an
opportunity to create sort of an
investment approach that was focused on
buying
you know cryptocurrency assets directly
in a way that nobody was really doing in
any sort of systematic way
and so in 2016 i decided to leave
coinbase and launch polychain to start
doing early stage investments in
cryptocurrency protocols
polychain's what's known as an early
stage or sort of seed investor in the
cryptocurrency space that means that
they tend to invest early on with check
sizes somewhere between 2 million 20
million dollars and they like to be one
of the first major institutional backers
of a novel company from the very
beginning polychain really occupied an
interesting
space in in silicon valley
it launched with four million dollars of
olaf's own money but he also had some
major backers in the form of inducing
horowitz and sequoia which are true blue
chip firms in silicon valley and union
square adventures based here in new york
which is also one of the the most
preeminent crypto backers out there and
they were able to kind of like straddle
that that space between some of the
novel crypto entrepreneurs and and old
silicon valley money which helped
catapult it
as far as polychain's growth there were
a couple of things that really benefited
olaf uh for one because he worked at
coinbase because he was in silicon
valley he was friends and intimately
knew many of the people that ran the
companies that received his first
investment checks he was already
intimately familiar with those projects
those founders and had essentially done
much of the technical due diligence
perhaps unwittingly
so that really helped them but but the
second step and this is what's perhaps
most interesting is polychain was built
not just to
provide money and perhaps some
recruiting and regulatory support but i
mean olaf has built a team of over 40
people that like to get their hands
dirty they actually have an active role
in supporting the networks and this
model that they've created is not
something that other silicon valley
venture firms had
but many are now starting to follow that
model
police started with four million dollars
and that that quickly searched over 200
million uh during the ic album uh
nowadays the firm manages about 5
billion and olaf's personal net worth
has surged to 600 million dollars
i would say that the more ambitious i've
been about investing the better success
i've had the projects that sound
the most crazy
in my experience have often been the
best returns
those are entrepreneurs going after new
paradigms or completely new business
models that are
genuinely unproven and those are
oftentimes
the things that define an entire
category or an entire technology
if i've learned anything it's
nobody can dream big enough like this
has all gotten so much bigger than any
of us imagined 10 years ago
and
i think that we're still underestimating
how big it will be when it eventually
replaces the global financial
system with this software substrate
one of the things that really stands out
about olaf is this sort of a sense of
personal style and his his
approachability he doesn't look like a
venture capitalist where you think of
the um like the patagonia vests and the
all-bird shoes
he doesn't fit that mold when we
interviewed him he was wearing a tie-dye
green t-shirt that he bought at a store
in mexico city
and he really kind of sees himself i
think as a bit of an individualist or an
iconoclast which
helps make him relatable to some of the
companies that he he invests in
he likes to invest in subversive
technology which certainly applies to a
privacy focused blockchain
but then aside from that i mean
olaf as as polychain has grown as the
ecosystem has expanded he's built up
his his company so it has much more
formalized processes and can scale um he
had to learn the business of actually
being a venture capitalist from things
such as deal structuring and term sheets
to to taxes um he's he's done all that
and uh and and the company is is now
working to try to replicate that same
level of growth now at a much higher
scale across a much more diverse set of
verticals
my long-term goal is a
globally accessible and highly
democratized
monetary system and financial system
that is not controlled
by
any central party or any elites
but rather is controlled by the network
of users and
any sort of activity or innovation there
anybody can participate in and so it's
you know it doesn't solve any of the
problems of a capitalist system but it
does take away a lot of the
centralizing forces of that system that
i think are not just negative like if we
can remove central locus of control and
replace it with a decentralized system i
think it has the
we we could
you know massively democratize the kind
of global financial system and i think
it has a huge rippling impact for
average people around the entire world
that can bear fruit when it comes to the
way that his company invests and
operates in this decentralized finance
space or or defy often times when they
invest and get tokens which are used to
essentially operate the network by
issuing proposals and voting on perhaps
like new product roadmaps or fee changes
in the networks they vote actively he
expects his team to vote on everything
that is of consequence for the network
and in many cases they have the ability
almost by themselves to reach a quorum
and pass votes and make sure that the
platform goes in the direction that that
they wanted to this level of
centralization or de facto
centralization is not something that
many people realize and and to be fair
that doesn't mean that olaf and other
crypto hedge funds and metro capitalists
are doing things malicious from
everything i've seen they have all
intentions of being good positive benign
influences on these networks because
they see
an opportunity where all boats rise if
they succeed then everybody else
succeeds but at the same time this is a
little bit of a liability that many
people don't quite realize and in some
ways it is a fair question to ask
whether or not these groups are
qualified to more or less run banks
which are what these things are um but
this is all part of the process this is
all part of what makes crypto so so
exciting and olaf and polychain are very
much at the forefront of it
so olaf i grew up in in minnesota
it's a very cold and boring place
i spent a lot of time playing video
games and on the internet
and i don't know what it is exactly
about that but i think it somehow set me
up to
both
find bitcoin early as well as understand
how it could be a big deal and you know
once i found out about it i got really
obsessed with it
after junior year of college he put
essentially all of his life savings 700
into into bitcoin um at prices ranging
from two dollars to 16 and and got
really excited about the project he
actually did his senior thesis on on
bitcoin and some of the the technologies
and and game theory that helped uh make
blockchain technology work and then he
ended up applying to coinbase by
emailing his thesis to coinbase's
founders brian armstrong and frederson
that's how he ended up moving over there
and working with them in a basically a
small apartment as what would become one
of the world's most important crypto
exchanges
by the time i uh joined coinbase i
actually had quite a bit of experience
relatively speaking
for a category that was only you know
three years old i realized that
you know while i didn't feel like
a traditional investor when i thought of
that my head i usually thought of
somebody on on wall street at a private
equity firm or i thought of somebody in
a patagonia vest
in sandhill road
i realized that i was uniquely set up to
really have insights here
um just because of the amount of time i
had spent in the category so even though
um
when i launched polychain i was
kind of rogue and independent right i
didn't have any sort of investing
experience in a formal way
um
really the only investments i'd ever
made in my life were in cryptocurrency i
mean bitcoin was the first investment i
ever made in my life
i think olaf is an idealist and a
realist olof is certainly an idealist
when it comes to blockchain technology
and and decentralization uh i don't
think anybody could look at the way that
the internet is constituted today and
think that it's truly equitable fair and
and rewards and and wealth are
distributed in a uh an inequitable
manner and and blockchain technology
certainly has a way of perhaps cutting
through
some of those barriers that have have
been directed by some of the the the
major technology companies and platforms
that have found themselves under fire
from
from their their clients from regulators
alike um that said he is also a
pragmatist and this kind of bears out in
a number of different ways i mean for
one
um there are some people that will think
it's sort of um anathema to crypto to
work at a centralized exchange like
coinbase or fund future decentralized
exchanges and and brokerages um that
could be in some ways like sacrilege but
olaf feels that there is a need for some
of these centralized entities that
operate on top of blockchains that offer
simple and intuitive on-ramps and
off-ramps so that people that are not
crypto natives can can get involved into
the space
he also
is a pragmatist when it comes to running
his company i mean he has a fiduciary
responsibility to to his investors he
has to find ways to stretch gains
whenever he can
for many years people were extremely
skeptical of the prospect of sort of a
global money system run over the
internet by a software you know based
protocol it just seems too abstract it's
almost too futuristic to feel like it
could really happen but
once people really dive in and
understand
the basics of how it works i do think in
general once people wrap their head
around this area
they sort of can't unsee it the genie is
sort of out of the bottle and it's very
hard to go back to viewing you know the
alternative or status quo system as
viable
if this whole
thing works i think it's the largest
wealth transfer in kind of the shortest
period of time in human history it
doesn't fix problems like wealth
inequality but it does in a sense sort
of shake the snow globe so it it
radically alters the logic of property
ownership and who owns what and how
global monetary systems work
so i think the opportunity is absolutely
massive and
one thing that's very cool about it is
people like me can participate in that
it's not limited to
you know the old guard
you know legacy financial elites
olaf has a few hurdles as he
sort of embarks on this next uh chapter
in poly chain and looks to put that 750
million dollars worth of dry powder to
work uh for one he's not going to have
the same type of head start that he did
when he first started polychain back in
2016. uh for instance one of the real
hot areas right now are our nfts and
metaverse the online gaming
and there's a different company and a
milker brands which has really taken the
bull by the horns and invested in many
of the blue chip companies such as
dapper labs and sandbox and axe infinity
at their very very very early stages um
so polychain's not going to be able to
replicate that part of the d5 playbook
to to nfts and other areas of growth um
that said um he's been working
diligently to build out polychain
building infrastructure so he can scale
up deal with the the pitches he receives
every day and and be able to provide
that same level of service to his
companies uh aside from that i mean
other challenges include a much more
competitive vc space in general two of
his peers andrews and horowitz and
paradigm have each raised multi-billion
dollar venture rounds which are more
than what polychain has brought in even
though um it's an important distinction
to make is that those companies tend to
also invest in later rounds which
require nine figure check sizes and
that's not something that that olaf is
is very interested in doing uh katie
hond who used to help run andrews and
horowitz descriptive firm just broke
down on her own and is looking to raise
a 900 million dollar round of funding
and then regulation and and sort of
governments i mean as crypto has gotten
bigger and grown more and more
governments are starting to pay
attention and they're going to look at
this industry not just from
like an aml kyc anti-terror finance
point of view but also from a consumer
protection privacy data security lens
and and all those things are eventually
going to come to a head when it comes to
to crypto so as olaf is doing due
diligence on these companies trying to
figure out the um the right portfolio
companies to bring into the firm figure
out the how much money he wants to
invest the due diligence process and the
support that he's going to have to
provide to his portfolio companies is
only going to expand from here on
[Music]
man i mean predicting five or 10 years
in crypto is
i would say insurmountable but i think
the next big step for the industry is to
make this
genuinely mainstream accessible from a
usability perspective
i think that
the traction we have
given the average
sort of user experience behind these
tools and applications
is really impressive so if we can fix a
lot of the
bad user experiences a lot of this
relates to key management as well as
abstracting away complex stuff like
public keys
that are sort of scary and look like
passwords
i think that if we can make better and
better consumer experiences
that's how we onboard sort of the next
billion people
long term i'm happy to have been
involved in sort of the early days of
getting cryptocurrency off the ground
and
i want to spend
more time sort of fostering emergent
artists and
i sort of want to start seed investing
but in artists in addition to
entrepreneurs
i have two older brothers and they're
both poets and so i've watched sort of
firsthand
how hard it is as a really good artist
to get off the ground and it's something
i think i would really enjoy helping
with people in the future
[Music]
you